[Music]
vegas is one of like my favorite places
to visit
there's so many amazing places just an
hour away a picture is worth
a thousand words in this day and time
it's worth
thousands of followers with circa with
stadium swim
the visuals are just incredible fletch
brunell is the vice president of
marketing for lvcba
the new tool for selling las vegas
travel influencers
so we have influencers that are foodies
in the culinary world
we've got influencers that like outdoors
we work with those that have at least 30
000 followers all the way up to several
hundred thousand followers and we've
also got individuals that we target
either by
gender demographic or by the type of
thing that they like to follow
it's not always about the number of
followers they have at lvcva they use a
platform called captivate to validate
the type of people following the
influencers
i have uh 190 000 followers
one influencer anna linares travels
around the globe
a lot of them follow me for my travels
others uh
follow me for the products that i love
and so it's a really nice mix of an
audience that i have
clinare says there is meaning behind all
her posts
three posts already up one of the
bellagio that had this
amazing view there's an amazing
restaurant called uh saddles and now
through the use of an instagram reel
influencers hope to connect with their
followers and relate a message
in less than 10 seconds it really
becomes
like a platform of creativity the travel
influencer side
specifically has such a force
possibly more than just an advertisement
in a magazine
because you actually bring to life the
place that you're visiting and it should
not
be underestimated it has been effective
so when we take a look at our
reports back in terms of number of views
number of likes
whether or not it is the videos that are
shown whether or not
it's pictures whether or not it's reels
we find that there's a lot of
activation that happens